Leah Thomas was interviewed what what
was this for was this the vice or like
one it's one of these things you can see
it's a they them interviewer and they're
talking to Leah Thomas about trans and
dudes swimming with chicks and the whole
damn thing take a look
the NCAA has said that they support
trans athletes they also haven't taken
action against states that have banned
trans athletes Leah can two truths exist
at once I think it's very difficult for
for an organization to say we support
trans people we support trans inclusion
and then not do anything to sort of
do that to anything to protect trans
athletes to ensure uh they're they're
treated fairly it's sort of
gets to this this broader idea that I've
encountered a lot where people will say
oh like Leah I respect you and your
identity as a woman but I just don't
think it's fair for you to play in the
women's category and you can't have that
sort of
halfway acceptance of of trans women and
of trans people more broadly because
when you think like that you're not
really
thinking of trans women as women you're
thinking of um as this other category
that we have to find something to do
with when we're just other women who
want to compete
no you are not other women who want to
compete you are a dude you have a penis
this is where I mentioned the Conor
propeller penis Theory which is that
Leah Thomas has kept the penis to swim
as a woman using the penis as some kind
of propeller for extra propulsion okay
so no I don't ex I don't respect you as
a woman I don't respect your pronouns or
anything else you're a dude who is a
marginal swimmer at best who is now
smacking down actual women and you're
doing it in the name of diversity and
tolerance you're a fraud and a phony
that's what you are
[Music]
thank you